in this cloud minute I'll show you how  you can you stack driver debugger to add  logging statements to a running  application I have a Python application  running on App Engine I've also set up  this application in stackdriver debugger  to add a log point I click on the line  number where I want to add the log and  then specify the content of the log  message  I can reference local variables by  surrounding them with curly braces I can  also specify under what conditions the  message should be logged I want to log  every time this point is hit so I'll  leave it to the default which is true  now when a user hits that path the  message will be logged I can see the  results down below I hope you don't have  any issues that require production  debugging but if you do lot of points is  another great tool to have in your  toolbox